L
CONTEMPT CHARGE IN THE WORDS OF
TRUMP LOYALIST STEVE BANNON
OVER HIS DEFIANCE OF THE
JANUARY 6TH SELECT COMMITTEE.
BANNON IGNORING A SUBPOENA
DEADLINE HE FACED TODAY.
OUR SENIOR LEGAL AFFAIRS
CORRESPONDENT PAULA REID IS
FOLLOWING THIS.
PAULA AS IT LOOKS THAT THEY ARE
NOT MESSING AROUND.
>> NO THEY ARE NOT MESSING
AROUND.
IN FACT WOLF THEY ARE SENDING A
MESSAGE TO BANNON AND OTHER
WITNESSES THEY ARE TARGETING IN
THIS INVESTIGATION THAT IF YOU
THEY YOU DON'T COMPLY, THEY
WILL TRY TO FORCE YOU.
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT IS A LENGTHY
PROCESS.
IT HAS TO GO THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE AND THE HOUSE AND
IT'S UP TO ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND WHETHER TO
PROSECUTE.
>> TONIGHT, LAWMAKERS
INVESTIGATING JANUARY 6TH MOVED
TO HOLD LONGTIME TRUMP ADVISOR
STEVE BANNON IN CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT AFTER HE DEFIED THEIR
SUBPOENA TO SIT FOR A
DEPOSITION TODAY.
IN A STATEMENT THE COMMITTED
CHAIRMAN SAID HE WILL NOT
TOLERATE DEFIANCE OF OUR
SUBPOENAS SO WE MUST MOVE
FORWARD.
>> WE ARE NOT FOOLING AROUND.
WE EXPECT PEOPLE TO FULFILL
THEIR LAWFUL DUTIES.
>> BANNON HAS REPEATEDLY SAID
HE WILL NOT COMPLY UNLESS
ORDERED BY A COURT, NOTING THAT
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE
WILL INVOKE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE
AND HAS DIRECTED BANNON NOT TO
PARTICIPATE.
IN A LETTER TO LAWMAKERS,
BANNON'S LAWYER WROTE THAT IS
AN ISSUE BETWEEN THE COMMITTEE
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP'S COUNSEL
AND MR. BANNON IS NOT REQUIRED
TO RESPOND AT THIS TIME.
WHILE LAWMAKERS TOOK TO THE
AIRWAVES TO SEE THEIR SEEKING
THE TRUTH, BIDEN DIDN'T EVEN
ADDRESS IT IN HIS PODCAST OUT
TODAY.
INSTEAD, JUST REPEATING THE BIG
LIE.
>> STOLEN ELECTIONS HAVE
CATASTROPHIC CONSEQUENCES AND
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE SEEING IN
THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
ARE YOU DOING THIS AFTERNOON?
>> BANNON WAS NOT THE ONLY
NO-SHOW ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
SOURCES TELL CNN SAID THE
COMMITTEE AGREED TO SHORE
POSTPONE OR THE SCHEDULE
DISPOSITION FOR A TRUMP --
KASH PATEL.
MULTIPLE SOURCES TELL PATEL
CONTINUES TO ENGAGE WITH
LAWMAKERS BUT IN A PODCAST
INTERVIEW THURSDAY,
REPRESENTATIVE ADAM SHIFT
REFERRED TO PATEL AS AN EVIL
ZEALOT WHO IS WILLING TO DO
ANYTHING TRUMP WANTED.
>> AND HE ROSE PHOENIX LIKE
THROUGH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, ONE POSITION
AFTER ANOTHER EVEN CONTEMPLATED
TO TAKE OVER THE CIA.
>> SCHIFF ALSO SAID THAT THE
COMMITTEE IS INTERESTED HOW
TRUMP TRIED TO PRESSURE JUST OF
OFFICIAL JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS --
YESTERDAY THEY SENT ANOTHER
SUBPOENA TO JEFFREY CLARK.
INVESTIGATORS CITE CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE THAT HE WAS INVOLVED
TO INTERRUPT PEACEFUL TRANSFER
OF POWER, EVEN PROPOSING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SENT A
LETTER TO STATE LEGISLATORS IN
GEORGIA AND OTHER STATES
SUGGESTING THE DELAY
CERTIFICATION OF ELECTION
RESULTS.
A SOURCE FAMILIAR WITH HIS
COMMENTS SAID IT WAS UNLIKELY
HE WILL TESTIFY.
ON WEDNESDAY, FORMER ACTING
ATTORNEY JEFFREY ROSEN WHO
PUSHED BACK ON CLARK'S EFFORTS
TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION SPOKE
WITH INVESTIGATORS FOR 8 HOURS.
TRUMP CAN STILL FILE A LEGAL
CHALLENGE TO TRIED AND BLOCKED
REQUESTS FROM THE COMMITTEE BUT
IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER HE WILL
BE SUCCESSFUL.
ON WEDNESDAY, HE ISSUED A
STATEMENT SAYING REPUBLICANS
WON'T VOTE IN 2022 OR 2024 IF
2020 ELECTION FRAUD IS NOT
QUOTE SOLVED.
>> TRUMP RELEASED A STATEMENT
TODAY ATTACKING THE COMMITTEE
SAYING IT SHOULD HOLD ITSELF IN
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT.
NOW FORMER TRUMP ADVISERS MARK
METALS AND SCAVINO WERE
SCHEDULED TO APPEAR TOMORROW
BUT THIS COMMITTEE AS DECIDED
TO POSTPONE THOSE DEPOSITIONS.
>> CRIMINAL CONTEMPT VERY
SERIOUS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PILLORIED
REPORTING FOR US.
LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF THIS WITH
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ADVENT INVESTIGATING
THE JANUARY 6TH ATTACK.
BENNY THOMPSON.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, I
KNOW YOU'RE MOVING AHEAD WITH
HOLDINGS DEED THEN MADDENING
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT.
HOW WILL THIS WORK?
I KNOW YOU'RE MEETING TUESDAY
WITH YOUR COMMITTEE AND THEN
THIS GOES WHERE IN THE TENS OF
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT?
>> WELL IT IS PROCESS WOLF.
WHETHER WAY THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
THE PROCESS STARTS WITH OBVIOUS
MISS LEAVING ON THURSDAY
EVENING.
WE WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
HOLD STEVE BANNON IN CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT.
THAT PROCESS THEN WILL BE
FORWARDED FOR CONSIDERATION BY
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
IF THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
AGREE WITH THE STANDING
COMMITTEES RECOMMENDATION THEN
THE SPEAKER WILL BE AUTHORIZED
TO TRANSMIT THAT DOCUMENT TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IT'S THEN HIS JOB TO PURSUE THE
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT CLAIM.
>> HAS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND MISTER CHAIRMAN
TOLD YOU HE IS WILLING TO
PROSECUTE CRIMINAL INDICTMENT
IF IT IS REFERRED BY THE HOUSE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE?
>> NO, WE HAVE INTENTION THAT
WAS KEPT OURSELVES SEPARATED
FROM JUSTICE.
WE DON'T WANT ANYONE SAYING YOU
WERE ALL COLLUDING TOGETHER.
THIS IS WHAT THE LAW REQUIRES
US TO DO.
I HOPE THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
ONCE HE GETS IT, HE WILL LOOK
AT IT AND SAY WE NEED TO
EXPEDITE THIS INDICTMENT FOR A
GRAND JURY.
SO WE KEPT AT ARMS LENGTH AWAY,
WE HAVE SHARED THE COMMITTEES
WISHES.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY TRIED TO
NEGOTIATE TO WORK THIS A
WITHOUT SUBPOENA.
BUT STEVE BANNON AND HIS HIS
ADVICE FROM FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP LEADS US LEAVES US NO
CHOICE.
SO THE COMMITTEE WILL DO WHAT
WE ARE REQUIRED TO DO.
IN THE LEGISLATION THAT SAYS WE
HAVE TO FIND THE FACTS.
WE THINK STEVE BANNON HAS
INFORMATION THAT IS JERMAINE TO
WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY 6TH,
AND IF HE REFUSES THE SUBPOENA
LIKE WE EXPECT HIM TO CAN YOU
TO DO, THEN WE ARE LEFT WITH NO
OTHER CHOICE THEN TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE DEPARTMENT,
LOCK HIM UP, HOLD HIM IN
CONTEMPT, AND CLEARLY THAT
MIGHT SEND ENOUGH OF A MESSAGE
THAT HE WILL AGREE TO TALK TO.
US >> BUT AS YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN, PROSECUTING BANNON OR
OTHER WITNESSES FOR THAT MATTER
COULD TAKE A LONG, LONG TIME,
MAYBE YEARS.
SO REALISTICALLY, WHAT IS THE
GOAL OF CRIMINAL CONTEMPT?
TO REALLY THINK YOU WILL COMPEL
TESTIMONY OR IS THIS MEANT TO
SEND A POWERFUL MESSAGE TO
OTHER WITNESSES?
>> WELL I THINK IT'S BOTH WOLF.
WHAT WE WANT TO DO IS GET TO
THE FACTS.
WE COULD SUPPORT A CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT OR WE COULD LOOK AT A
CIVIL CONTEMPT.
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS
AVAILABLE TO US, BUT WE THINK
THE CRIMINAL GETS US TO BEAR
WHERE WE NEED TO BE IN THE
SHORTEST PERIOD OF TIME.
WE HAVE TO GET ALL THE
INFORMATION.
WE HAVE RECEIVED THOUSANDS OF
PAGES OF INFORMATION FROM
DIFFERENT AGENCIES ABOUT WHAT
THEY WERE DOING DURING THIS
PROCESS.
THE PLATFORMS, FACEBOOK, GOOGLE
ALL OF THEM HAVE REALLY
COOPERATED SUBSTANTIALLY IN
PROVIDING US INFORMATION TO DO
OUR WORK, BUT NOW WE HAVE TO
TALK TO SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY STARTED THIS PROCESS.
>> I KNOW YOU HAVE AGREED AT
LEAST IF NOT TO POSTPONE THE OF
MARK MEADOWS AND KASH PATEL.
ISN'T IT POTENTIALLY A TO RUN
OUT THE CLOCK IN THESE TRUMP
APPOINTEES.
>> WELL WE DON'T EXPECT TO RUN
OUT THE CLOCK.
WE'RE GONNA MAKE THE CASE THAT
WE NEGOTIATED IN GOOD FAITH
WITH THE OTHER 3.
IF WE DECIDE THAT THE
NEGOTIATIONS IN FACT ARE
RUNNING OUT THE CLOCK, WE WILL
STOP IT.
BUT IF WE --
WE HAVE TO MAKE OUR ARGUMENT WE
GAVE THE PROCESS EVERY ATTEMPT
TO WORK.
THAT'S WHAT WE PLAN TO DO.
WE HAVE IN MR. BANNON'S
INSTANCE HE HAS JUSTIFIED
EVERYTHING.
SO WE ARE MOVING EXPEDITIOUSLY
ON THE CRIMINAL CONTEMPT.
WE EXPECT THAT PROCESS TO GO
FORWARD THIS COMING TUESDAY
NIGHT.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A TIME OF 7
30, THE COMMITTEE WILL MEET, WE
EXPECT WE WILL TAKE ACTION ON